>> This one is true, especially for large data sets. In each of these samples,
our sample size is only 10. So here we don't exactly have 50 percent of the
data, but it's pretty close. And this will more and more closely approximate 50
percent as the data set gets larger. Think of it this way. We split the data in
half. We split it in half. And we split it in half here. If this is 25 percent,
this is another 25 percent, another 25 percent, and another. Then here between
Q1 and Q3, we'll have about 50 percent. This one's false. We could make this one
a lot bigger, and the IQR would still be the same. However, we could change this
if we made it, say, 59,000. Then the IQR would get a little bigger. If we made
54,135 bigger than 60,181, then this would be the new Q3. So sometimes certain
values can influence the IQR, but it's not affected by every value in the data
set. And the same concept applies here. We have this outlier, but even if this
were something closer to the data set, like 63,000, the IQR would still stay the
same. So this one's true.